congratulations on this show this show's
addictive like first
20 minutes in i was like um my new
favorite show yes it is oh
amazing yeah so congratulations um
this show is being billed as gossip girl
of the regency era
do you think that that's an accurate
description uh claudia let's go through
first
um i mean it's always nice to have
people say that it reminds me of this
and that because these are things that
people already love
and you know to merge those things
together is wonderful
obviously we've got these incredible set
of novels that were our
our foundation written by the amazing
julia quinn and sort of like
happened before a gossip girl and sort
of like the idea of scandal sort of
happened has been happening forever and
i think we love gossip
we also love to journey back to a time
no longer
with us because we can fantasize about
what it was like so um
yeah i can see how people do that but
it's uh it's very much its own thing
whilst it is obviously set in the early
1800s and it's stunning and yes there is
a mysterious anonymous scribbler
it's also got that beautiful shonda
modern pace which makes it so uh
contemporary
and perfect for our audience
um how amazing is it having the legend
herself
julie andrews as the narrator as lady
whistle down i mean she's she's sassy
oh yeah this is julie andrews being
really naughty which is
such a delight because when the show
opens and you hear that voice it's so
iconic and unmistakable
and when i found out she got cast i just
burst into tears i was like
too overwhelming to like think about
being in a show with her
but they could not have gotten anyone
better for this role and i think it just
sets the tone
for the whole series it's just like the
thought that judy andrews
may possibly might know who we are is
like it's too much
it's too like i need to like find myself
and lie down when i think about it
it's like dream come true for me it's
yeah oh 100
yes oh that's amazing um you know
obviously this is a period piece but
we're definitely
seeing universal themes of love um
friendship family um what are you
excited
for viewers to see when it comes to this
show
well we've already got such an
incredible
fan base that come again with these
incredible novels
and so we're really excited to sort of
enter their territory they've been
you know in love with these books for
such a long time i'm sure they've
you know fantasized about what an
adaptation would be like
and so everyone must be overjoyed to
hear that netflix and schondelen this
like power
collaboration have come together to do
it i mean it couldn't be in safer hands
so i'm excited for people to be welcomed
into this world
and it's such a delicious looking world
to be and like welcomed into me and
nicola always sort of describe it as
like
a big box of like really shiny
chocolates
you know that you get at christmas those
really good ones sort of thrown at the
screen with like immense amounts of
talent
so yeah i'm excited for people to feel
like they're a part of the world
that it is because it's complete fantasy
and the most beautiful
escapism and um it's so warm and there
are so many touching
touching moments in it but also like one
of the most exciting things to watch as
i'm sure you
feel as well i love that you're in love
with it
that's good it's it's such a feast for
the eyes i mean it really is like aside
from all the drama suffering being just
a good show like
visually i'm like this is one of the
most beautiful shows on television right
now
um so i have to ask like how much fun is
it getting into those costumes and
seeing
the food and working on these incredible
sets
it's absolutely phenomenal you feel like
a little kid playing dress up because
you literally go into the room and you
know that scene in um pretty woman
where she goes into the store and they
they they're like mary kate louise and
they get all the stuff for her
it's like very that so they make all the
costumes from scratch there's a jeweler
on set there's someone that hand
embellishes everything
then we got to film in those beautiful
locations all over the country these
amazing
houses in which these balls really
happened at the time and you walk in and
everyone looks so spectacular it feels
like there's been a time machine
and you're transported back and it looks
so spectacular on screen it's hard to
believe that you're really
proud of it yeah oh that's so exciting
um
i i'm getting the wrap but really
quickly uh nikola is there any update
uh when it comes to dairy girls season
three because fans want it
oh my goodness well i'm so glad to hear
that and yes it's written and ready to
go we're
just waiting for the green light when
it's all covered safe but i already know
all of the story lines and i am so so
excited i genuinely i'm not just saying
this i think it'll be the best one that
we make
i'm so excited yeah that's a big
statement that's exciting
for fans i should say hello to my auntie
and cousins in canada as well or they'll
be very annoyed at me
well congratulations on the show um i
cannot wait for the rest of my family to
see it because like i know they're going
to be as addicted
as i am so congrats oh that's so lovely
to hear thank you so much
thank you so much it's nice to meet you
you